réponse cinglante de la chine à l'om
est-ce l'organisation mondiale de la
santé avait demandé la semaine dernière
la poursuite de l' enquête sur des
origines du coc u19 fait notamment un
audit c'était laboratoire chinois dans
les régions où est apparu le virus fin
mais pékin a décidé de rejeter sa
proposition une attitude jugée
irresponsable pour les états unis
pour en parler on trouve tout de suite
notre reporter à washington thomas
mollet fera bonsoir ce jeudi la porte
parole de la maison blanche a répondu
aux propos chinois oui et les enquêtes
sur l'origine du covin 19 sont toujours
source de tensions diplomatiques entre
pékin et washington vous l'avais dit la
semaine dernière l'om est sa demande est
de poursuivre les enquêtes notamment
pour réaliser un audit des laboratoires
situés dans la région dans la région
chinoise où les premiers cas ont été
recensés vous propose d'écouter la
réaction de pékin à cette demande de loi
n'est ce chercheur à temps pour être
honnête quand j'ai d'abord vu la
proposition de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé d'une deuxième étape de
l'enquète sur l'origine du coville 19
j'ai été extrêmement surpris ce plan
retient l'hypothèse d'une violation par
la chine des procédures de laboratoire à
l'origine de la fuite de virus comme l
une des priorités de recherche à partir
de ça je peux sentir le manque de
respect pour le bon sens et une
arrogance envers la science dans ce plan
coatex nationale en main et c'est donc à
cette déclaration et plus généralement
sur la position de la chine que la porte
parole de la maison blanche a été invité
à réagir elle s'est exprimée il ya
quelques heures depuis washington
écoutez donc elle jen psaki depuis la
maison blanche
nous avons bien entendu vu les
commentaires de la république populaire
de chine rejetant à nouveau la phase ii
de l'étude de l' oms nous sommes
profondément déçus leurs positions et
irresponsable et franchement dangereuse
aux côtés d'autres états membres du
monde
entier nous continuons à demander à la
chine de fournir l'accès nécessaire aux
données aux échantillons c'est essentiel
pour que nous puissions comprendre et
prévenir la prochaine sont des femmes
il s'agit de sauver des vies à l'avenir
et ce n'est pas le moment de faire
obstruction
voilà donc pour cette nouvelle passe
d'armes entre les deux puissances dont
les sujets de discorde ne manquent pas
alors sur l'origine du coc vide
la thèse d'une fuite de laboratoire a
été pendant très longtemps balayé
notamment ici aux etats unis avant
finalement de prendre du poids auprès
des autorités et illustration de cela et
bien en mars dernier joe biden a demandé
un rapport à ses services de
renseignement un rapport qu'il va lui
être remis sous 90 jours ce qui nous
conduit à la fin du mois d'août
justement sur cette hypothèse d'une
suite de laboratoire c'est une hypothèse
qui est rejetée évidemment par pékin qui
qualifie cette hypothèse de rumeurs
infondées et quelqu'un de son côté
demande une enquête sur un laboratoire
américain le laboratoire de fort detrick
qui se situe à près de washington selon
le quotidien chinois global times une
pétition a recueilli cinq millions de
signatures pour que justement une
enquête soit ouverte sur ce laboratoire
américain
il ya donc les accusations politiques en
ce qui concerne en revanche les
conclusions des experts de l oms ils ont
estimé qu'une fuite de laboratoire était
un scénario extrêmement improbables ce
sujet en tout cas de l'origine du commis
19 pourrait être abordée très
prochainement puisque la numéro deux de
la diplomatie américaine est
actuellement en déplacement en chine
c'est le déplacement c'est le premier
déplacement d'uniterre aussi importante
côté américain depuis l'élection de joe
biden en chine
merci beaucoup thomas bonnet pour toutes
ces précisions en direct depuis
washington